so far I think the winter 2020 seasons
been one exhilarating ride with a lot of
nice shows showing us that no matter the
season of the year anime is just getting
better and better now with that out of
the way I'd like to take this time to
look ahead in a few weeks the spring
2020 anime season will officially start
and as early as now I'd like to
introduce some of the shows that I find
interesting from that season from what I
can see these are some of the shows that
many people are anticipating and I'm
sure you might be able to find something
you'd like somewhere down the line for
now we leave the current anime season
and head forward fast forward a few
months into spring 2020
[Music]
being an ordinary kid in a boring town
can be uninspiring needless to say it's
these kinds of people who get all sorts
of wacky powers in anime and kaguya's
which is no exception
however instead of stock powers like a
magical weapon or super-strength he ends
up with the ability to transform into a
dog mascot with a gun and a zipper down
his back
it gets wilder when he meets and saves
Claire having shared his secret with her
Shuichi finds himself being used by
claire in her quest to find her sister
how long will our protagonist sanity
hold out is it a crazy premise yes is it
out there
absolutely how about the fanservice
check the images from the manga yourself
having read some of the manga I promised
left knee is one wild ride that you
won't want to miss nevertheless I have
to warn you it can get really weird and
uncomfortable at some points I did not
expect this to get an animator
[Music]
Aparri Tron man sees the awkward Serrano
affari and Samurai is she ki kasam a
teaming up broke and trapped in America
the to enter the trans America wild race
with nothing to lose they rush through
America in their steam-powered car
enticed by the prize money that's
promised to the winner of the race going
from LA to New York may seem impossible
but when geniuses team up nothing
not bandits rivals or challenges the
unforgiving land of American can throw
at them can stop them with a bar a Ron
man being an anime original project we
can only wait and see if PA works will
knock it out of the park from the
trailer the series seems fun and crazy
and I think this could be the sleeper
here the season took them long enough to
animate steel ball run jokes aside let's
see if PA works his latest venture can
end up being the big success that
surprisingly puts the community on
notice this spring the North Ameena
blocks introduce us to memorable shows
like Psychopaths your lie in April and
AnoHana
this time we're in for a mystery anime
fugu kg balance unlimited is the
adaptation of a mystery novel about two
detectives the materialistic Daisuke who
finds himself completely appalled by his
partner harus attitude then again as
they say opposites attract and make the
best combination as mysteries unfold the
detectives in spite of their contrasting
personalities must work together to
solve them given that clover works the
one behind Babylonia and the promise
Neverland are handling this I expect
some tip-top designs and animation with
the recent resurgence of mystery anime
let's see if fugu kg Balance unlimited
can help continue the momentum and lead
a boom in the genre
[Music]
gingka famous for their signature art
style and stories that are crazy in a
fun way studio trigger looks to once
again make their presence felt with BNA
bien a brand new animals is sent in a
world of humanoid animals Mathura turns
into a tanuki one day and she makes a
way to anima city meeting and teaming up
with Ogami shiro Mathura who starts her
journey to make sense of her
transformation and get to the bottom of
everything with the recent B stars and
Dora Hedorah being hits I can kind of
see why trigger would go for something
like this I mean overall it looks
interesting we can only wait and see
what wackiness trigger has installed for
us this time around let me say that it's
also from the guys behind little witch
academia and kill la kill given how well
those shows turned out expectations are
high for B na will trigger save anime
once again there's only one way to find
out and just like that it's a chi once
again finds a way to reinvent itself you
see the reason why the genres continue
to thrive is that it manages to get very
creative with every little area it can
brawl the notorious derivative nasaan
Rajas closer inspection helps you
conclude that while we may have numerous
clones of shield hero each clone has a
distinctive charm point that draws in
fans from all directions or time a game
now Hamed su takes things a bit
differently instead of being sent to
another world as a chosen one or a hero
our protagonist finds herself
reincarnated into a villainous yep dying
sent her to the world of a favorite game
fortune lover now harnessing her
knowledge of games and possible routes
Katarina Kleist looks to find
contentment for herself will she be able
to avoid certain doom and find her happy
ending I mean come to think of it why
hasn't anyone thought of this before
having the protagonist reincarnated as a
villain err seems out of the left field
yet ingenious at the same time I'm very
excited to see how this one goes
I can't believe they did this war of
underworld the grand finale of sword art
online Salas ization arc aired several
months ago then they suddenly split it
into two
yep the split core got divided into an
extra split core leaving us with another
cliffhanger during the Christmas season
amazing
this time the billing of this batch
being the grand finale is no joke just
like the rest of the war
after dazzling us with their creative
abilities and featured fights most of
the integrity nights now take a back
seat as the og crew come in prepared to
see more of
Asuna Leifer sin on and the rest of the
gang in action as they race against time
to save Kirito and fend off the forces
of the dark territory Sao fans rejoice
you epic finale has come and you won't
have to wait too long for the glorious
return of the black swordsman which
timeline are we living in with snafu
getting a 3rd season I guess it's the
best timeline for anime fans really
after several years we finally get the
continuation of the ever popular school
series not with an OVA not with a movie
a full season yeah it came out of
nowhere but I guess this snafu
dakimakura us that just got released a
year ago managed a fun season 3 of
course I'm kidding and that's not the
whole picture really is it with the
light novel concluding a while back fans
who once only hope they would get a full
adaptation of the story in anime form
should be ecstatic as it looks like
we're headed into that direction those
who grew up loving Hachi man Yuki no Yui
and the rest of the squad will be in for
a treat as the third season of snafu
promises even more twists and
developments with the characters
relationships
Archie Mars coming-of-age story from his
season one form looks to continue and we
all eagerly await the next chapters of
his and the rest of the gangs lives or
another caveat Ivana studies Nina if
you've been watching my recent videos
it's no surprise that I'm a big big fan
of Kaguya sama love is war a fun and
extremely entertaining series given the
unique simple premise it was one of the
most popular shows of the past year
looks like the anime gods have given us
all a gift in advance with the
announcement of the second season of the
hit romantic comedy it's a good thing
they didn't pull
attack on Titan and make us wait half a
decade before the inevitable sequel we
won't have to wait that long to see more
of Kaguya my Yuki and chica the
hilarious misadventures of the trio
continued will we finally see a
confession and a victor in the crazy war
of love you just have to wait and see up
next on the list we take a look at Tower
of God one of the most popular webtoons
right now 25th pounds of boy who spent
his life of isolation inside a cave
underneath the tower chasing his best
friend Rachel BAM enters the tower he's
told that he'll get the answers he seeks
should he find his way to the top of the
tower right before coming face to face
with a deadly test grasping onto the
possibility of reuniting with Rachel
BAM keeps going scaling the tower that
continues to provide various challenges
within each floor I'm a big fan of the
series it's amazing in terms of world
building badass characters and action it
promises a world of adventure that's
made it into one of the best web comics
out there the footage that I'm showing
right now is the promotional material
for the webtoon and the games there's
nothing better to do than wait for the
anime adaptation that will surely show
you why Tower of God has indeed itself
to the hearts of many fans the suffering
continues and Subaru is back at it with
his dark misadventures in another world
back in 2016 Reesie Row was the biggest
hit in town capturing the hearts of many
as one of the darker and more cynical
yokai series that took the world by
storm to this day I still think it's
arguably one of the best it's a guy
series that's reached the mainstream
I think the first season left off in a
pretty decent place but we all agree
that the story must continue in some
form this season a Subarus fight remains
unfinished as more members of the sin
Archbishop's lurk in the horizon
recruiting the help of the newfound
allies from the fight battle against
Bethel geese Subaru and Amelia prepare
to fight the next major battle in their
journey wait did I just go without
mentioning REM
the most popular character and
everyone's waifu half a decade ago well
you got to watch the second season and
maybe the memes and jokes from several
years ago will finally make sense
2020s gone off to a wild start and so
has the anime side of things with
numerous highly anticipated sequels
headlining a season full of unique in
promising anime spring looks to start
the 2020 anime year with a bang which of
the sequels and non sequel works are you
most excited for please let me know in
the comments section below as always I'd
appreciate your like and sub don't
forget to follow me on Twitter if you
haven't already and I hope to see you
again next time on Vinny Chiu
[Music]